une fin de règne mouvementé à moins d'un
mois de son départ de la maison blanche
donald trump demeure fidèle à son style
présidentiel quitte à s'aliéner son
propre camp l'un des derniers dossiers
sensibles en date
l'adoption du budget de la défense le
président américain est farouchement
opposé à la version adoptée par le
parlement
et il ya mis son veto ce mercredi qu'à
cela ne tienne les deux chambres
y compris donc le sénat pourtant
majoritairement républicain ont annoncé
un vote dans les prochains jours pour
outrepasser le veto présidentiel
un véritable camouflet pour la maison
blanche plus important encore l'adoption
du plan de relance de l'économie
américaine pour faire face aux
conséquences de l'épidémie de kobe 19
le texte prévoyait initialement
d'allouer une aide financière de 600
euros aux américains en difficulté trop
peu selon donald trump
je demande au congrès d'amendé ce projet
de loi est d'augmenter les ridiculement
faible 600 $ à 2000 $ ou 4000 $ pour un
couple
je demande également au congrès de se
débarrasser des éléments inutiles et
coûteux de cette loi et de m'envoyer un
projet de loi appropriée
sinon ce sera la prochaine
administration qui sera chargé de
fournir un plan de relance qu une
annonce qui a pris de court les élus
républicains les démocrates eux ont
sauté sur l'occasion et ont déposé ce
jeudi un amendement en ce sens et si
donald trump n'a pas prononcé le mot
veto nous la washington ne doute qu'ils
soient déterminées à en user pour
certains il pourrait s'agir d'une
vengeance du locataire de la maison
blanche
plusieurs sénateurs républicains ont en
effet récemment reconnu la victoire de
joe biden aux élections de novembre
une trahison pour le président
républicain qui n'a de cesse de
contester les résultats du scrutin et de
crier à la fraude
j'ai sauvé au moins huit sénateurs
républicains dont mitch dont la défaite
lors de la dernière élection
présidentielle truquée maintenant ils
s'assoient presque tous et me regarde me
battre contre un ennemi tordu et vicieux
les démocrates radicaux de gauche
je n'oublierai jamais les républicains
ont annoncé mercredi qu'il n'accèderait
pas à la requête de donald trump
d'augmenter les aides aux américains la
situation est donc dans l'impasse
d'autant que le plan de relance est lié
au budget du gouvernement pour 2021
la perspective du veto présidentiel fait
ainsi planer la menace d'un nouveau choc
town c'est à dire un arrêt partiel des
activités gouvernementales et du même
coup la suspension du versement des
salaires de nombreux fonctionnaires
il y a deux ans un désaccord entre
donald trump et le congrès avait déjà
débouché sur une situation similaire le
shakedown avait alors duré plus d'un
mois le plus long de l'histoire des
états unis